your new favorite show house of the
dragon the game of thrones prequel
series is currently filming
and it's coming in 2022 on hbo
based on george rr martin's book fire
and blood it tells the story of the
dance of the dragons
a targaryen civil war of succession
between aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first round
these days you're able to see many house
of the dragon's set photos
which serve as a little promo or tease
for what is about to come
rhaenyra targaryen and daemon targaryen
are the only characters we see in these
photos
here you can see them filming on the set
that's been in production for the past
week on hollywell beach in cornwall
they're in full regal targaryen costume
they share the scenes speaking together
on the beach
and once they finish their conversation
rhaenyra then walk towards the sea
which is when the scene ends rhaenyra
and daemon are on driftmark
the seat of house valerian and this
scene takes place
after the bloody battle of the gullet so
who are these two characters
rhaenyra and daemon are the main
characters of our story
king viserys's chosen air a dragon rider
who grew up expecting to become the
first ruling queen of westeros
princess rhaenyra targaryen cheered as
the realms delight
when she was young and later called the
half-year queen
was the first born child of king viserys
the first targaryen
rhaenyra was king viserys as the first
only living child by his first wife
queen emma of house sarin at the age of
eight she was made her father's heir
and grew up expecting to become the
first ruling queen of westeros
rhaenyra was a dragon rider whose mount
was xyrex
rhaenyra had her family's valyrian looks
burying her silver gold hair
in a long braid in the manner of queen
visenya targaryen
beautiful as a child rhaenyra was later
declared by her uncle
later husband and the man who is
standing beside her in these photos
prince daemon targaryen to be the most
beautiful maiden in all the seven
kingdoms
daemon targaryen is also a key figure
from this time period
and is george r martin's favorite
targaryen
daemon targaryen also known as prince of
the city lord flee bottom and the rogue
prince
had many titles throughout his life
prince sir commander of the city watch
master of coin master of loss king of
the stepstones and an air of sea
protector of the realm daemon was the
most controversial man of his lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in
equal measure
there was never a man so loved and so
reviled
and at the same time as he was during
the dance of the dragons as the husband
of his niece rhaenyra he supported his
wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in astros
he was rhaenyra's second husband
following sterling or valerian
and she was his third wife prince daemon
was the most experienced warrior of his
time
and wielded the valyrian steel blade
dark sister
a dragon rider whose dragon was charaxis
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones
and the narrow sea daemon was a skilled
warrior
described in the histories as dashing
daring and dangerous
he was also ambitious impetuous
mercurial
immoral reckless and quick to take
offense
he is described as being as charming as
he was hot tempered
due to the lack of a male heir viserys
designated rhaenyra as his successor
therefore rhaenyra was the only female
targaryen to lay claim to the iron
throne in her own right
since she was raised as the designated
heir
raniere became quite pampered and
arrogant but also gained practical
governmental experience
after rhaenyra's mother died her father
remarried and had several sons by his
second wife
alice sent of house hightower even so
viserys still publicly expected his
daughter to succeed him
and when he died his official will even
stated so
however rhaenyra's younger half-brother
aegon
challenged her claim he stated that the
normal inheritance loss of the andals
which formed the basis of the unified
law code in westeros called for male
preference primogeniture
meaning that a younger son would
rightfully inherit before
an older daughter rhaenyra had two
husbands and five sons
her first husband was lenore of house
valerian
son of the seasoning lenora and rhaenyra
had three sons together
princess jacary jace lostris luke and
joffrey joff valerian
all were near adulthood and had dragons
of their own when rhaenyra's father
viserys the first died
it was rumored that those sons of
rhaenyras were actually fathered by her
champion and lover
harvin strong the strongest man in
westeros called breakbones
as all three were born with brown hair
and brown eyes
although lenore and rhinera both had
light silver gold hair and purple eyes
the greens were the ones who sparked
this rumor often calling them strongs
the true parentage of rhaenyra's three
eldest
children is still unclear the siblings
lanor and lena valerian who were married
to rhaenyra and daemon targaryen both
died in 120 ac
as did rhaenyra's alleged lover break
bones
rhaenyra then secretly married her uncle
prince daemon
the most experienced and the most
dangerous warrior of his time at
dragonstone
the news of their wedding caused a great
scandal at the court of king's landing
and made rhaenyra's father furious it
took some time before viserys and daemon
reconciled
rhaenyra's other sons princess aegon and
viserys targaryen were fathered by
daemon
and all had targaryen features at the
time of her father's death
rhaenyra was on dragonstone evading the
birth of her child
the green sinking's landing ensured that
the news of viserys's death did not
reach her
until her own supporters in the red keep
were dead or imprisoned
and dagon the second's coronation had
already occurred
this began a devastating civil war that
tore apart
the seven kingdoms known as the dance of
the dragons
as it was the only war in which both
sides had the dragonriders
these scenes right here take place after
the bloody asc battle in westeros
history
there's an upturned shipwrecked hall
being set up by carpenters on the
location
the presence of a leftover shipwreck as
many of you guessed correctly
points to the battle of the gallant the
battle of the gullet also called
the battle in the gullet was a battle
that took place in the gullet in 130 ac
during the dance of the dragons it
remains among the bloodiest
sea battles in all of history house
valerian blockaded the gullet
and controlled access to black water bay
at the start of the civil war
after the assault on harrenhal by prince
daemon targaryen
and further blows to the greens serrato
hightower the hand of the king to aegon
ii targaryen
hatched a plan to break the valyrian's
fleet's blockade
otto reached out across the narrow sea
to enemies so prince daemon the triarchy
hoping to persuade him to move against
the sea snake
lord corliss valerian otto's plan took
time
and dagon ii eventually ran out of
patience with his grandfather's
prevarications
replacing him as hand with sir kristen
cole
the schemes of otto eventually bore
fruit
as the high council of the triarchy
accepted his offer of alliance in tyrosh
90 warships commanded swept from the
stepstones under the banners of the
three daughters
bending their oars for the gullet
meanwhile on dragonstone it was decided
by prince jacarius valerian that his
half-brothers princess aegon and viserys
targaryen
would be fostered with a prince of
pentos until their mother queen rhaenyra
targaryen had secured the iron throne
the princes departed on a ship towards
the end of 129 ac
the sea snakes sent seven of his
warships with them as escort
their ships encountered the triarchy's
fleet which had sailed up to the gullet
it was taken captive and warships were
sunk or captured
possessed only of a dragon egg viserys
had no way of escaping from the ship
and was made captain aegon escaped on
his young dragon storm cloud
sailors attempted to bring them down and
stormcloud was wounded by arrows and
scorpion bolts
nevertheless they flew to dragonstone
where aegon delivered the news of the
threat from the east
storm cloud died at dragonstone from his
wounds
the battle began on the fifth day of the
new year 1 30 ac
the triarchist ships divided into two
squadrons entering the gullet to the
north and south of dragonstone
they attacked at sunrise surprising
house valerian's fleet
flying on vermax to meet the fleet of
the triarchy
prince jacary solarian swept down upon
enemy galleys
the sailors had experience fighting
prince daemon targaryen and his dragon
characters
during the war for the stepstones so
their captains directed their spears and
arrows
against jacarys one ship caught on fire
and then another however
when jacarys was joined by off the white
on silverwing
nettleson sheepstealer adam valerian and
sea smoke and hugh hammer on vermithorn
the line of warships from the three
cities shattered as one galley after
another
turned away vermix flew too low however
and crashed down into the sea possibly
wounded from a crossbow bolt to the
eye or pulled down by a grapnel survivor
said he struggled in the rigging of a
burning galley and sank with it
jacary slipped free but was then killed
by mirish crossbowmen
north and south of dragonstone the
battle continued into night time
the southern squadron bypassed the
dragonstone
believing that it was too strong to
assault and instead attacked the
driftmark
setting a fire the harbor of spicetown
with fire ships
the town was sacked with its inhabitants
butchered
the high tide and the treasures of lord
corliss valerian were burned by mirish
and tyroshi soldiers
with the sea snake servants cut down as
they fled
these scenes here take place a day or
two after that
as rhaenyra and daemon return to see
what's left of driftmark
discussing their next moves i hope these
photos of rhaenyra and daemon targaryen
made you even more excited for the
upcoming
epic game of thrones prequel series
house of the dragon
thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one
peace